ladies and gentlemen well become
again this time for the conference
of michel barnier the chief negotiator
of the european union for the agreement on
the future relations between the
european union and the united kingdom barnier
you have the floor
thank you eric hello to  each and every one
of you sorry to hold your
attention a little longer
today to realize
he says sorry to you for
realizing this first round of negotiations on
our future relationship with the British team
as you know this  new
negotiation aims to
build or rebuild an
ambitious new partnership with this great country
which, beyond the bric sites and attractions,
the objective will remain a neighboring country, friends
and allies, but we must rebuild everything or
almost everything on
different legal bases in  because of the
breakbeat and so we started this work in
a serious and constructive way
with de david frost who is leading
the  he negotiation on the British side and
with our two negotiation teams these
are the exceptional teams by
their number nearly 110 people on
each side 120 people also by
their skills which are made up
of experts on the British side
representatives of the various ministries
all the services  concerned and on the side
of the union obviously 22 directorate
general
of the european commission the
external action service is obviously at our
side those kataria general of the council
you will allow me to say here a
personal word of thanks to
president ursula von der leyen  to his
office for the trust and
support they have shown me to
build this negotiating team
is also to build a
fairly original cross-functional work in this
house with all the commissioners,
their team and the general management
for as we speak  with one
voice,
therefore, I would like to thank both
British sides  and Europeans all
the people involved in this
negotiation and thank them for their
professionalism and once
again their cordial and constructive spirit so
they have shown I should show you
as I have undertaken to report to you
today on this first round
which  is only a first round as of
its difficulties of its progress and we
must also alternately in london
is here after each round
it is moreover the same spirit of
transparency that we had
throughout the previous negotiation
we  will continue I will continue to
inform to consult to listen to the
member states the 27 is a number not of
which we are negotiating who would make one
they come to the council this afternoon
but also to listen to consult the
member states during my visits to each
capital where I meet the  national parliaments
professional
trade union representatives civil society
many other stakeholders
and government  of each of these countries
and we will have the same permanent concern
for transparency and trust with the
european parliament with the
coordination group of this parliament which is
currently led by david mcallister
and each of the parliamentary committees
first of all a word from the  context of this
negotiation which is a very
demanding context very negligent we have
this year
in fact three projects which are as
many challenges to lead in parallel not
only one the first project is the
implementation of the withdrawal agreement I do not  am
not trivial
we have concluded after
three and a half years of negotiations with the
government of boris johnson
an agreement which was then ratified in the
house of commons and in the
european parliament in this agreement it concerns the
rights of four million  and a half of
citizens and on the side it must be guaranteed
and each European united kingdom must
do their job to guarantee the
rights thus obtained by these four
million and  half of people until the
end of the year 2001
it is also a question in this
peace agreement of the stability in ireland and in
northern ireland within the framework of the good
friday agreements all the obligations
of the united kingdom and all the  obligations
of the european union have been clearly
defined in this agreement which organizes an
orderly withdrawal between the united kingdom and
the union repeats and david frost whom i
interviewed confirmed to me this week
that the united kingdom would respect all its
legal commitments  it is indeed a condition
of the confidence that we need
now to build
our future partnership on good foundations and as regards the
Irish protocol which is important and
complex I recognize that the time is
not for negotiation
it  it's about implementing a
precise agreement and doing it together in
a pragmatic way in an
operational way and I know that it's becoming
urgent for example for companies
in northern ireland who need  in the absence of
clarity from the authorities of
the united kingdom on this implementation,
we will follow this implementation
very closely and on a regular basis
within the joint john committee which
is provided for in the treaty in
collaboration on my side with the
vice  - president sefcovic who will co-chair
this committee as desired and decided by
the president of the commission
here is the first project and I remind you
that this treaty must be implemented
on January 1st and therefore everything
must be done methodically for step
by step
succeed in this implementation our
second project is not
trivial either 4 then I call on you
to carry this message in your newspapers
and your media
it consists in preparing us on both
sides for the changes that will take
place in any event  whether there is an
economic agreement or not in any
event prepare us for the changes
which will take place on January 1, 2021
on this date which nothing changes in the
pos  ition of boris johnson and his
government
oriole munis
will leave will have left
the customs union and the single market on december 31
that's the end of the transition
that's what that means what a
transition that doesn't  is not extended as
it could by a year or two on
December 31 in the united kingdom left the
customs union and the market and that has a lot of
consequences ladies and gentlemen for
which we must prepare ourselves in
any event it will no longer be business
as usual  that I recommend not to
understand January 1, 2021
as we lived on January 1,
2020 it will be very different
I have the impression why I am telling you
this with a little vehemence that on one
side as on the other the
definitive changes that will occur due
to the united kingdom's decision and the
difficulties that are linked to these
changes
I have the impression that they are often
underestimated
I gave two or three examples on
January 1 of the formalities  years will be
applied to all our imports
and all our exports with the
United Kingdom and will do the same thing on its
side that day on January 1st
of the financial institutions established in
the United Kingdom automatically losing the
benefit of the financial passport this is
one of the  consequences of the 6 pt break
third example British authorization
or certification of the books
and will no longer allow a product to be
placed on the European market
whether it is a vehicle for
industrial goods or even medical devices these
are the consequences of the principle  and these
are the final consequences
of the uk leaving
the single market and customs union on 31 december
as it wanted and i
mean the future partnership that we
are negotiating as ambitious as it is and
we have a lot  of ambition will
not avoid its points of friction which we
have moreover with the other
third countries and the British delegation has
r  acknowledging this point in no way
I therefore want to thank once again
all the member states on our side
their administrations and the companies
which must accelerate their preparation for
these changes since these changes
will occur with certainty in less
than ten months now
here is the second  project the third
project is obviously that of the
reconstruction through this new
negotiation of a strong relationship and an
ambitious partnership with the united kingdom
we must do it in a
constrained time which is the time chosen by
the british
since they have  decided not to
extend this transition
we will make every
effort to build the foundation of our
future partnership online and in
compliance with the political declaration
agreed on October 17 with boris
johnson
I will say not only by mutual agreement but to
negotiate our  hamlets and line to line
with boris johnson and his team
but whatever the  he constraints
of this time which is imposed chosen by
the united kingdom I want to say in an
extremely clear way that we will defend
on our side in this negotiation
the interests of our citizens of our
consumers of European workers
and European companies
here is for the context I would like
now to talk about the results of
this first round
as you know last week
the 27 member states meeting within the
council approved our
negotiating mandate in this mandate
you find the ambition of an
economic
and security partnership without  precedent with an
equally ambitious trade agreement
which covers all goods without
tariffs and without quotas which covers
services investment
intellectual property
public procurement and fisheries and which must be
based and will be based on
fair conditions of competition this
point  also is in line with the
political statement
from his side the govt  erment of the
united kingdom published its approach its own
mandate for its own team on the
future of the association the basis of these
two documents
this first round was therefore a
necessary opportunity to exchange to confront the
points of view to compare to
clarify  ask questions by
identifying points of convergence and points
of divergence we therefore opened
eleven parallel negotiation tables on Monday and Tuesday morning
on all
the subjects of the political declaration
except foreign policy and
defense since the United Kingdom is
indicating to us  that they did not wish to
negotiate a particular agreement on these
major subjects, we have taken note of this and
obviously for us the table remains
open for this negotiation if the
United Kingdom wishes it later on
the rest of the subjects which have been the subject
of all these tables we see
convergences on the horizon on some of
our objectives and some
specific points I am thinking of the  cooperation
on civil nuclear power or the
participation of the united kingdom in certain
programs of the union
these are a few examples but to be
completely frank i must be frank
with you there are a lot
of differences and
very serious differences it is without  natural doubt
after a very first round of
negotiations I would like for your
information to mention four areas of
divergence that we will have to resolve if
we want to progress
first of all obviously the question of
what is called level playing field
in our political declaration
we  we agreed with the
united kingdom to prevent trade distortions on both sides and
also to prevent unjustified competitive advantages
we also
agreed to maintain high standards
as is normal in a
trade policy of  our time which
is not the same time as there are 40 in
one as
modern and sustainable business practices in this premie  r
round the British tell us that
they still have this ambition for
high standards as we have
ourselves but there are two difficulties
the British do not want to translate
these commitments into a common agreement
they do not want
appropriate mechanisms either  to ensure
compliance on both sides if we
agree to maintain
high standards
the question I am asking why
not formally commit to
it is also a question of trust
here is the first point of difference the
second  point relates to
judicial and police cooperation
in criminal matters we want
cooperation in this area commensurate
with our common interests, commensurate with
the requirement of security for them
citizens of the entire European continent,
also commensurate with
geographical proximity  and our shared challenges
whether it is the fight against
terrorism against organized crime or
against money laundering
a cooperation  Ambitious action in this
area requires a commitment on
both sides to the
fundamental rights of individuals,
but the United Kingdom has informed us that
it does not want to make a formal commitment to
continue to apply the
European Convention on Human Rights.  nor does he
want the European Court of Justice to
fully play its role in
the interpretation of European law
and when we talk about the security of
judicial and police cooperation
we are also talking about the exchange of
personal data, sometimes very
personal data such as  the exchange of
dna data in this area this
is an essential point for us with
regard to the protection of the rights
of european citizens
the interpretation of european law will not be
done and cannot be killed by the
european court of justice on
thursday this  point is serious because if the
British position is maintained it
would have had an immediate effect which is
concrete on the ambition of our
cooperation which remains  will be possible on the
basis of international conventions
but which cannot be as
ambitious as we would like a
third point of divergence relates
to the governance of our future agreement
and horizontal provisions the
united kingdom insists on concluding a
multitude of serial agreements
sectoral offer of specific agreement on a case-
by-case basis where it deems
necessary we do not understand
why while we are negotiating on
all these subjects in parallel in
a very short time and in coherence
we should be moving towards a
myriad of  individual or
sectoral agreements why not include
our future relationship in a
global framework this is what we have proposed
through this legal basis for our
side of an association agreement
and this point ladies and gentlemen is
not a  ideological question
I have a practical question
horizontal governance would ensure an
effective agreement avoiding the
unnecessary multiplication of  e structure
parallel agreement with
separate ratification procedures a
lasting agreement that stands the agreement
the test of time and provides
legal certainty for our
businesses consumers citizens and an
ambitious agreement that does not limit  our
capacity for dialogue and cooperation
to be ready to meet possible
new challenges in the future
is topical in terms of the
health crisis shows that it would
be in our interest to always be ready to have
rapid and coordinated responses
with preparation  sufficient
here is the third point the long I'm
talking about divergence is the fourth
point concerns fisheries
the united kingdom does not want
the fisheries agreement to be part of our
economic agreement
it wishes to negotiate in particular
reciprocal access to British waters
and Europeans on an annual basis
, which I take the liberty of telling you
as the former Minister of Fisheries of
my country
absolutely  nt impractical it is about a
hundred species
is what we can do with
norway the over five species is not
possible over a hundred species is
also not possible if we want to
give all anglers  concerned on both
sides a readability and
predictability that they need i
am going to be very clear on this in
accordance with the mandate i have received a
trade and economic agreement with
the uk will have to include a
balanced solution for
ladies and gentlemen fishing  is rich so
different sources like has no on
price and special one one negotiations
this sum a very very difficult for
ever continue to believe that we can
reach good agreements forbo files this
past few days have been constructive
police
le guen l'acte 5 david frost  we estimate
tim small competent professional glassware
via the wiiware
of which the shooting of uk civil
mobile services continues or a discreet camera
individuals in lomé before mans gesture  ion
and share with you to not so ball which
distort excess of a love one new game
back and our commitment anywhere
youtube wisbecq you leave void est ni
mist understanding the uk aspects of
the native ten week in six lines on x
independence designers human nobody nobody
disputes uk independence nobody uk
everyone respects our own in
dependence deep down that he respects uk
sovereignty just had to do this
condition
opening up market by hugh this
openx market for good and services by
repression 19 beats having to endure all
in dependence to hold back is what we do
with our respective independence so
like a challenge 7 p.m. all a
grid stems dependence
together in large you type make it
possible for us to cooperate all stiff
a title to  an approved center together to
maintain consistent in comparable and
stand up overtime to protect citizens
so designed we have 15 years off
planet here is if we keep these
conditions  mind the party gives
all along the ramps come i think i
sincerely think a deal is
possible even if it is difficult in a
moment after a few of your
questions we have scheduled a time
clara martinez my deputy for lina
paths director will be able
with all the team leaders on
the task side I think I can answer
questions as precisely as possible in the context
of a technical briefing like that,
I am at your disposal
thank you very much sir  barnier we
had two questions first here
right man is then jane's his wave
reached per year noz this barber the two
questions if you lose the
joint committee first
you could explain a bit
how it works is what there is
already have sessions scheduled or have
a work plan and second question
concerns uncle the close one for the
different agreements on the different
sectors
I do not really see where the
contradiction is  ion is it not possible to
make different agreements on the
different sectors and to make a
government with identical governance
for each agreement would not be
possible
the john committee is precisely provided for
in the withdrawal agreement we are putting it
in place and its  first meeting should
be held on march 30 next
on the british side i understand that
it is michael gove who could be the
minister responsible for monitoring this
implementation under the authority of the
first it is on the other side the
president ursula von  der leyen has
appointed maros sefcovic our
vice-president or on whose side I will
work with my team for in
particular this whole year where the
work is very important
since this year it is a question of using the time
so that the agreement is operational on
December 31 and this time is short
there is a lot of work on the
citizens
and indeed on Ireland here is the
time we inform you of
the agenda of these meetings which will take place
will hold regularly which will be
the subject of reports
obviously there will be agreements which have
a different nature since their subject
their different subject a free
trade agreement including, as
we formally request, the level pain
field and fishing related to the other subjects
economic has its own identity it
is not the same thing as an agreement on
a eurojust prüm or anti money
laundering postponement so there will be draft agreements at the end
of the negotiation tables
we will I hope
probably  quickly enough to work on the
basis of legal texts to speed up
to give an additional chance to
the negotiation but what you say is
clearly what is at issue, that is to
say that we want a
common governance framework and that is what  the
most tannic disputes so this is where
we have a real point of difference
that I wanted to say earlier
there is in my introduction I
would like to recall obj facts  workers
which, moreover, the British side has
recognized and which they must
prepare for on their side with
British companies and the British administrative services, just
as we
must prepare ourselves
these are the changes which are
inevitable and definitive and the
inevitable and definitive changes which are the
concrete automatic consequences of the
fact that the United Kingdom, which can work
alone on December 31, the subject you are
talking about, which is a very serious subject,
is on the subjects of the negotiation I
am not going today when we
are just starting to discuss  and we
noted our disagreement on the question
of fishing I am not going to tell you
what the outcome of this negotiation will be
I cannot prejudge I simply said
that we are ready to find with the
British on this subject while
respecting sovereignty  United Kingdom
in the common interest of the
fishing communities on both sides who fish
and then export their products from
p  fishing for a large part
who process their fishing products
are all these problems that are
linked which are obviously trade problems
that is why we are including this subject
in the trade agreement we are
ready to find a balanced solution on these subjects
here is  but I cannot tell you
today with certainty
what the outcome of this negotiation will be,
I simply said since your
question allows me to tell you again that
for the member states on whose behalf I am
negotiating for all the member states
an agreement  a balanced solution on
fishing will have to be part of the trade agreement
if we want a trade agreement
some women treated on the fly
but I don't have much to add to
your
question thank you for asking it
because  that it is one of the questions of
astonishment that I saw but by reading the
mandate of negotiation that the
British are enough on their own to
negotiate with Mr trem  pe and from this
time the good success in this
negotiation that the united kingdom
naturally owes in application of maxit it is
necessary which renegotiates all their
commercial agreements and I wish the best
for this negotiation that I was
interested to see that he wanted a
base of  level playing field is therefore
obviously the context is different
the proximity is different I wanted to set
up the days on 7 slide
economic geographic proximity but the
philosophy to use a word that
david frost himself uses very
often
the philosophy is the same we
will need each other  'a level
playing field agreement to secure what was
promised by boris johnson and by
european leaders in the
political declaration flight from enemy iron
competitive to lace just avoid
distortions of competition and that is
what i have  called ladies and gentlemen
since we are talking about philosophy a
modern and sustainable trade agreement we are going to
put in these arrangements  rds for all the
agreements that have just been born one day
with the united states with other
more distant countries ideas of
reciprocal guarantees agreements to live up to
the expectations of
citizens consumers employees of
climate change
this is what  what I call a lasting
and progress agreement so it seems to us
that a mutual agreement
ensuring that it is a common standard
ensuring regulatory consistency
that's what I was saying earlier
what do we do with  our
independence that of the united kingdom that
no one disputes is ours
how we use our independence if
I may say so to have
regulatory consistency in certain
areas and avoid bad
competition that's the question and I
was happy to see  that the united kingdom was
paving the way for this and in its
next discussion with the united states
what is written in our agreements and that
we are going to respect its two sisters
we will  let's omen possible drop
so many kids everything to reach an
agreement so that we said that for fishing
because it's a very difficult
dangerous job to be fishermen I have a lot
of respect for the men and women
who exercise this  profession
they need visibility and
legibility
so we are going to do our best to
reach an agreement on fishing
if we do not succeed in July we are
setting the objective of reaching this agreement
within the overall framework of the
economic agreement with the  united kingdom that's
the goal I will have a few
more months left we are going to do our pool
of rucks for you too by the way
you have mentioned other subjects which
for me are not about getting us
into trade off where we  have made a
commitment to lower both
the wines for the assessment that we
must do on the side of the commission
for future financial equivalence
and also for future adequacy
decisions in the field of state
and directi  competent general ons of
the commission under the authority of the
competent commissioner june der on the one hand
those of brodsky from aude have started this
asset work weeks what we are
going to do normally 4 with
very complex techniques and i hope
that  we will have finished as we
wish around the summer after the
decisions itself of india and kouassi and
the decision itself of equivalent
will be taken later within the framework of
our responsibility to us and in the
case of our  decision-making autonomy
I mean by this that there is no
negotiation on this subject that I have just
mentioned
there will obviously be dialogues but
there is no negotiation these will be
decisions taken by the
British from  autonomously within the
framework of their independence and we
will make our own
decisions on the equivalence or adequacy
of the six young people for the states within the
framework of our responsibility for our
independence
yes but he will have he has so  I can say
that we continue to face
this crisis in a very pragmatic way,
still taking into account the decisions
that are taken on the income side I
saw the Prime Minister's announcements yesterday
on the European side according to
the evolution of de  this virus so I
would not be I do not want to make a commitment
nor we have planned a timetable for
the moment circulation in our two
countries for people who are not
sick is entirely possible is
open meetings are not prohibited  in
France or in other countries we have
banned large gatherings
we are very numerous in this
negotiation but neither we are maximum
200 in the same room and often in
separate rooms so game we will take
all the precautions promises you to
carry out  this negotiation and to
preserve the health of those who
lead it or who participated here are therefore
games and journalists who come to
pose genes to ask questions
it's the Lille result if I
add moreover it's one of the points that I
mentioned because these are subjects that have
interested me
for a very long time I even wrote a
book a few years ago on the
major risks in the world
an atlas v twenty years ago I
am very attached to the question of the
risks of risk prevention and this
is one of the questions I
asked in relation to these new
health risks  and human and animal diseases
we do not need to anticipate
and plan frameworks for cooperation game this
is one of the questions that i asked
for the negotiation between the united kingdom
and us i think it is one like one
interest to have such frameworks
in advance i apologize i can't
pass it on to
others other good of assistance at the
moment you are going to have now the
technical briefing all senses a bit
rushed by  time and you can
definitely get some answers in
the next episode.  event so I am
now calling my colleagues from the
technical boeing task force with lady
thank you very much thank you see you very soon